mon habité ces gens Noel Barrault
ministre délégué en charge de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications j'en ai le barreau
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes un peu
le monsieur tech du gouvernement ça
tombe bien il y a beaucoup
d'interrogations en ce moment il y a
beaucoup de
grogne de révolte même qui montre contre
chat dupy qui pourtant révolutionne tout
on voit bien que ça soit l'éducation
nationale que ça soit notre métier de
journaliste le métier de photographe on
reviendra un petit peu plus tard vous
avez entendu donc
Eric Bothorel député que vous connaissez
la Renaissance porte plainte devant la
CNIL parce que dans chaque Zippy il y a
des informations fausses je me suis
livré à un exercice j'ai tapé Jean-Noël
Barrault sur ta gipiti et alors vous
êtes né en 1983 à Suresnes alors qu'en
fait vous êtes né dans le 7e
arrondissement en 1980 vous avez fait
des études à Oxford vous avez enseigné à
Cambridge alors que vous avez été HC et
vous avez été
bref il y a énormément en plus vous êtes
pas du tout ministre vous êtes toujours
député ça pour le coup c'est exact mais
par contre je savais pas que vous aviez
changé de partie vous n'êtes plus au
modem vous êtes à la Renaissance donc
c'est dire s'il y a énormément d'erreurs
est-ce que vous allez porter plainte
devant l'acnil vous voyez après la vague
d'enthousiasme des premiers jours succès
d'une vague d'inquiétude et de et de
critique très fortes sur Chat GPT qui
ont donné lieu en Italie à une décision
de la CNIL d'interdire purement et
simplement de chaque gepetti je crois
qu'il faut
raisons garder et voir ce qui dans
chatgi relève de la prouesse
technologique mais là où sont les
limites de tchadipty et de toute
évidence il y a un certain nombre de
questions qui se posent quand au respect
par chat GPT de notre réglementation sur
la protection de la vie privée des
données personnelles qui est le rgpd
c'est ce qu'elle souligné l'acné
l'italienne c'est ce que veut soulever
également Éric botterel quand il dit que
c'est ces AG une conversationnel tchat
GPT qui doivent s'entraîner sur des
échantillons très vastes de données et
bien ils n'ont pas tout à fait encore
dit la manière dont il comptait protéger
les données des personnes physiques
lorsque ces données-là figurent dans les
les jeux d'entraînement de ces modèles
et les CNIL européenne vont devoir se
mettre au travail pour et bien regarder
tout simplement si le rgpd est respecté
et sinon la manière dont nous devons
combiner la manière dont on encadre
l'intelligence artificielle d'un côté et
la manière dont on encadre la protection
de la vie privée de l'autre pour que
l'innovation en intelligence
artificielle puisse continuer de se
développer en Europe l'intelligence en
artificielle nous en avons besoin et
elle apporte beaucoup au quotidien pour
se déplacer se loger s'informer se
soigner pour que cela respecte un
certain nombre de principes auxquels
nous sommes très attachés mais du coup
est-ce que je vous repose la question
est-ce que vous allez porter plainte par
exemple dès lors que vous voyez que les
informations sur vous sont fausses ça
serait un signe fort quand même parce
que j'ai vérifié les biographies de
différentes personnes je peux vous dire
que c'est très faux et moi je m'en sors
plutôt bien donc je trouve ça formidable
mais vous voyez là la question ce que
nous faisons c'est d'une part au niveau
européen peut-être qu'on en reparlera
nous travaillons à règlement sur
l'intelligence la question et au niveau
français j'ai saisi au début de l'année
le Comité national pour l'éthique du
numérique qui va nous rendre un avis
dans quelques mois qui va couvrir ces
sujets là de respect par chat GPT les
autres agents conversationnel de ce
genre là leur conformité avec notre
notre réglementation
je vais la poser différemment est-ce que
vous soutenez la démarche du député Éric
Bothorel
la démarche d'Éric bottorell de toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent faire valoir
leurs droits devant la CNIL elle est
légitime ensuite si vous me demandez si
je trouve que la la décision de la CNIL
l'italienne d'interdire chat GPT était
la bonne ma réponse est non la réponse
la bonne réponse c'est de trouver le
cadre qui est à la fois protecteur des
données personnelles et de la vie privée
et à la fois propice au développement de
l'intelligence artificielle en Europe
sans quoi c'est ailleurs qu'elle se
développera et nous la subirons plutôt
que de la maîtriser d'accord mais en
même temps vous même vous avez 10
l'arguments des Italiens qui est de dire
ça ne reste respecte pas pardon le rgpd
donc
c'est peut-être eux qui ont raison parce
que le rgpd la France a participé c'est
c'est même eux l'acnil qui a été
l'initiative du RGP qui doit être un peu
plus précis dans les plaintes qui ont
été déposées devant l'acné l'italienne
et dans les motifs que l'acné
l'italienne a cité il y a deux choses la
première c'est que les utilisateurs de
chat GPT euh non pas fait l'objet ou non
pas été traité avec les précautions
d'usage quand on veut respecter le rgpd
à mon avis la société Open qui a créé le
chat GPT va se conformer à ses
obligations là mais la deuxième des
questions qui est soulevée c'est de
savoir si nos données personnelles qui
sont dans ces grands jeux de
d'entraînement utilisés pour le
développement de chat GPT sont
correctement protégés et ça c'est une
question qui est posée au rgpd dont nous
fêtons les cinq le cinquième
anniversaire cette année et qui à
l'époque a été conçu à un moment où ce
type de ce système d'intelligence
artificielle n'existait donc pour vous
la Cnil doit jouer ce rôle en fait de de
faisait pas de contrôle
technique européenne doivent nous
indiquer très clairement après avoir
fait leur travail si oui ou non le rgpd
est respecté et sinon nous proposer une
façon de faire évoluer notre cadre et
peut-être le rgpd 5 ans très sa création
pour faire en sorte que on protège les
données des citoyens européens tout en
permettant le développement de
l'innovation en Europe donc voilà il
faut peut-être faire évaluer évaluer le
cadre exactement ça c'est un point
important lorsqu'on regarde ce qui se
passe autour de l'intelligence
artificielle vous avez raison de dire si
on interdit attention ça va se
développer ailleurs évidemment c'est un
peu ce qui s'est passé en Chine mais qui
du coup essaye de rattraper le Mouvement
pour la France
dessin la France
de Google se de Meta etc sont dirigés
par des Français il y a 5 ans on a
constaté qu'on avait ses atouts là et le
président de la République a voulu
lancer une stratégie nationale consacrée
à l'intelligence artificielle à l'époque
il avait demandé un rapport à Cédric
Villani on a consacré un milliard et
demi d'euros à cette stratégie on a fait
naître des centres d'excellence qu'on a
appelé les instituts interdisciplinaires
pour l'intelligence artificielle à Nice
à Toulouse à Grenoble et à Paris et ces
instituts ont permis de décupler de
démultiplier le nombre de chercheurs le
nombre de doctorants et le nombre de
diplômés en lien qui a doublés
énormément là en ce moment qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez faire et est-ce que c'est à
VOUS gouvernement de faire quelque chose
il faut beaucoup de moyens derrière
quand même il faut des moyens c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette stratégie
nationale a été rechargée de 1,2
milliards d'euros supplémentaires il y a
deux ans dans le cadre de France 2030 le
grand plan d'investissement d'avenir et
ces crédits ont vocation à soutenir la
recherche universitaire la formation des
talents il y a 700 millions consacrés à
la formation des talents en IA et puis
bien évidemment soutenir
l'investissement des entreprises parce
qu'il en existe en France qui s'engage
pour développer des modèles comme chat
GPT la meilleure preuve c'est que avant
chaque GPT il y a un modèle que la
France a initié qui s'appelle Blum qui
qui est né en France grâce au
supercalculateur du CNRS et qui et qui a
qui est Open Source donc qui correspond
un peu plus à nos critères à nos à nos
préférences et donc et qui est une base
de départ pour que ce développement en
France des modèles comme chat gptt le
grand danger derrière avec le traitement
de ces données de ses fausses données
éventuelles c'est des données vont
savoir si vous êtes né en 80 83 c'est
c'est c'est dommage enfin c'est pas
fondamental par contre derrière c'est
toutes les données nuisibles et après on
va en dire un mot bien sûr parce que ça
c'était sur les données écrites
journalistiques près j'ai envie de dire
biographie mais derrière vous avez aussi
toute la question des images des images
qui sont traitées par d'autres d'autres
logiciels mais là aussi où on a bien vu
le pape en doudoune on a vu Emmanuel
Macron au milieu des manifestations donc
comment traiter ces effets nuisibles
enfin qui sont plus que nuisibles
au niveau l'Europe et le la première
démocratie du monde à s'être dit on va
créer un cadre pour le développement
de ce cadre c'est la transparence
lorsque une image sera créée avec
l'intelligence non avec le règlement sur
lia dont les députés européens sont en
train de régler les détails aujourd'hui
lorsque une image sera publiée qui a été
conçue avec l'intelligence artificielle
il faudra signaler que cela était le cas
pour que chacun puisse différencier
l'homme de la machine ce qui vient de
l'humain de ce qui vient de
l'intelligence artificielle et puis
ensuite
ce que disent règlement c'est qu'il y
aura des usages pour lesquels
l'intelligence artificielle est
interdite exemple la surveillance
générale des populations qui aura des
usages qui sont critiques pour
lesquelles l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle sera
conditionnée à des obligations de
transparence et d'audits avant la mise
sur le marché exemple le transport ou la
santé parce que lorsqu'il y a des
défaillances dans ces domaines-là ça
peut engager des vies humaines et puis
il y aura des usages qui sont moins
sensibles pour lesquelles l'intelligence
artificielle est librement utilisable ça
sera liax ça sera comme le dessin le DMA
c'est des actes qui vont être qui vont
s'appliquer par pour tout le monde au
sein de l'Union européenne absolument ça
fait partie de cet ensemble de
réglementation nouvelles que l'Europe
s'est dotée pour dire une chose simple
si vous voulez entrer sur le plus grand
marché économique du monde alors il vous
faut vous conformer un certain nombre de
principes auxquels nous Européens sommes
attachés la concurrence équitable
le respect de la vie privée puis
s'agissant de l'intelligence
artificielle et bien un certain nombre
d'usages qui sont interdits et puis le
respect d'obligation de transparence
pour que chacun puisse avoir quand il
est confronté à une image si oui ou non
elle a été conçue avec une intelligence
artificielle ça va sortir quand ça va
être adopté dans les prochains mois et
ça va commencer à s'appliquer à
l'horizon 2025 mais c'est loin 2025
ouais c'est ça c'est la lenteur c'est la
lenteur mais l'Europe est en avance
aucune démocratie dans le monde on sait
même pas où on sera en 2025 c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut anticiper
créer un cadre qui soit suffisamment
souple mais je le je le redis là où
l'Europe a commencé à poser un certain
nombre de bornes des bornes qui sont
d'ailleurs demandées par les acteurs
eux-mêmes le fondateur d'openhag que
j'ai rencontré au mois de janvier à San
Francisco chez openerg donc le
concepteur de crédit la première chose
qu'il m'a dit c'est il faut que la
puissance publique fixe un certain
nombre de bornes et c'est ce que
l'Europe s'est attaché à là où les
États-Unis n'ont rien fait par exemple
ce qui conduit ensuite bien des gens
comme Elon Musk a réclamé purement et
simplement un moratoire ce qui n'est ni
souhaitable ni réaliste je le disais il
y a aussi
tout ce qui concerne l'image qui
acquiète énormément que ça soit des
reporters d'image que ça soit évidemment
des photographes on avait mis de journée
délits tout il y a beaucoup de logiciels
comme ça qui se développent est-ce qu'il
faut revoir les les conditions des
droits d'auteur on sait que ça a été
extrêmement compliqué c'était un
processus très lent est-ce qu'il faut
revoir à l'aune de ce qui se passe
justement avec l'intelligence
artificielle dans le domaine de l'image
je le crois je pense qu'il y a un
certain nombre de problèmes qui sont
traités par le Règlement sur
l'intelligence artificielle on a évoqué
tout à l'heure les questions liées à
l'articulation entre l'intelligence
artificielle et le rgpd je crois qu'il y
a un troisième point qui est fondamental
qui est la juste rétribution des
créateurs pourquoi parce que
l'intelligence artificielle générative
n'est pas créative elle réagence des
contenus préexistants et ces contenus
ils ont été produits par quelqu’un par
des artistes par des journalistes et il
convient que ces artistes et ses
journalistes ils soient justement
rétribués et donc dans les mois les
années qui viennent il nous faudra
trouver une manière de faire en sorte
que celles et ceux dans les contenus
sont utilisés par les intelligences
artificielles pour générer des contenus
nouveaux puissent être dument rétribués
mais alors comment est-ce que ça sera ce
qu'on appelait ou ce qu'on appelait
l'octaus c'est-à-dire qu'il faut faire
la démarche ou alors il faut que ça soit
inclus dès le départ est-ce que ça sera
au niveau européen où ça sera dans parce
que pour l'instant il y a aucune mesure
qui on retrouve dans la dans les actes
il y a aucune mesure qui concerne
justement le droit à l'image et la
rémunération non c'est vrai et c'est une
réflexion qui commence tout juste
puisque bon il y a quelques mois chat
GPT n'existait pas à mi-journée non plus
c'est pour ça que quand vous me parlez
2025 je trouve ça fait très loin on sera
déjà passé à autre chose mais cette
question des droits d'auteur elle va
devoir et de propriétés intellectuelle
elle doit elle doit elle va devoir être
traitée et là encore ça malt man
dirigeant d'openhague concepteur de chat
gepetty lorsque je l'ai interrogé sur ce
sujet il m'a fait pas de sa conscience
du problème et qu'il fallait le régler
je crois qu'il y a déjà des contentions
en cours aux États-Unis en France et en
Europe on a avec les droits voisins
trouvés une solution pour l'une des
dimensions de la valorisation des
contenus produits par les journalistes
sur internet de la même manière il va
nous falloir trouver la manière de les
rétribuer lorsque leur contenu sont
réutilisés par l'intelligence
artificielle voilà mais est-ce qu'on
peut pas aller plus vite parce que c'est
là où le temps les politiques on parle
beaucoup de temps sur un autre sujet sur
lequel je vais pas vous interroger
évidemment celui des retraites mais le
temps politique n'est pas du tout le
temps du business comme encore moins le
temps du digital ou de l'attaque est-ce
que est-ce qu'il faut pas un peu
accélérer
je crois qu'on est déjà en avant sur le
reste du monde je crois qu'il faut
évidemment avancer rapidement mais sans
non plus donner l'impression que
l'Europe sert tous les boulons et
interdit toute forme de d'innovation
avant même de l'avoir vu naître sur son
sol donc il faut comme on a su le faire
dans d'autres domaines ces dernières
années trouver un cadre qui soit
suffisamment souple et propice à
l'innovation en Europe et à la fois
suffisamment protecteur pour les
citoyens mais aussi pour les créateurs
de contenu donc
n'est pas précipitations il faut trouver
une solution en tous les cas voilà le
Parlement de l'image si je vous dis tout
ça est un peu lent on peut aussi prendre
le sujet pardonnez-moi du métaverse
parce que vous avez demandé un rapport
qui vous a été remis donc en octobre
2022 mais j'ai envie de dire c'est
encore un rapport avec des mesures ou
est-ce que vous en êtes vous voyez
est-ce que il faut pas changer de
logique non on avance le logiciel
puisque pardon on est plutôt dans
logiciel on avance sur ce sujet de du
métaver et des univers immersifs qui
sont l'une des tendances qui qui va
définir l'Internet demain qui a beaucoup
qui a beaucoup d'applis qui a beaucoup
d'applications pour la culture
évidemment mais aussi pour l'industrie
la formation la santé j'ai annoncé cette
semaine le lancement d'une d'une
consultation publique d'une consultation
publique puisque jusqu'à présent nous
avions interrogé les experts nous sommes
arrivés à un certain nombre de
conclusions qui esquisse une stratégie
pour le métaver appliqué au domaine
économique que sont l'industrie la
formation la santé et avant de la de la
cristalliser nous avons souhaité faire
une consultation publique pour que
chacun puisse y contribuer y participer
à elle est ouverte sur le site de la
Direction Générale des Entreprises
jusqu'à début mai
oui d'accord
simplement oui on voit Disney qui arrête
son métaverse on voyait des entreprises
aussi est-ce que est-ce que quand même
il faut pas avoir une peut-être une
autre une autre démarche je me permets
d'assister parce que je me demande si
c'est la bonne réponse ce que vous nous
dites je crois que les les univers
immersifs auront dans les années qui
viennent des applications très sérieuses
et très concrètes et qui sont là et
quels sont là pour rester la chance que
nous avons c'est que en France des
acteurs comme d'assocystème dans le
domaine de l'industrie de la santé de la
ville intelligente des acteurs comme
Ubisoft dans le domaine du jeu vidéo
maîtrise les briques technologiques
sous-jacentes et donc avec les briques
technologiques sous-jacentes et le
savoir-faire français en matière à la
fois culturelle d'un côté mais aussi
industriel et en santé nous avons de
quoi développer une offre de bout en
bout des univers immersifs qui vont des
briques technologistes qu'on appelle les
moteurs jusqu'à la distribution des
contenus et sans savoir exactement ce à
quoi les Métavers seront au quotidien
dans 10 ans nous veillons à ce que dans
10 ans nous ne sommes pas dépendants de
grandes puissances les États-Unis la
Chine pour ne pas les suicider pour le
développement de ces technologies là
alors justement vous faites encore une
fois elles vont tordez une paire je vais
poursuivre avec Tik Tok et l'autre gros
dossier on est un peu j'ai envie de
reprendre la phrase de Gainsbourg il est
interdit d'interdire mais c'est vrai que
là il y a des questions aussi très
fortes autour de Tik Tok qui a un succès
fou auprès des jeunes et la question se
pose est-ce qu'il faut interdire Tik Tok
alors au niveau du gouvernement vous
avez j'espère vous n'avez plus
l'application Tik Tok sur votre
téléphone vous l'avez jamais eu non
d'accord est-ce qu'il faut interdire Tik
Tok je sais que le 10 mars je crois que
vous avez rencontré des dirigeants de
Tik Tok ils font une offensive
évidemment de communication pour
expliquer mais non on est prêt à montrer
patte blanche qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez
je réponds que nous avons interdit le
téléchargement des applications
récréactives comme TikTok comme
Instagram par exemple sur les téléphones
qui sont fournis par l'État aux agents
publics pourquoi est-ce que nous avons
fait cela parce que lorsqu'on s'inscrit
sur l'une de ces applications et TikTok
est un très bon exemple beaucoup de
données
du téléphone sont sollicités vous voyez
qu'on vous demande si vous êtes d'accord
de donner accès à vos contacts à vos
photos à votre agenda etc ces données là
qui sont collectés par les applications
en question elle présente le risque de
fuite et c'est ce que nous voulons
absolument éviter pour les téléphones
des agents publics donc nous avons pour
ceux qui sont pas membres du
gouvernement qui sont pas qui sont pas
qui sont le coma des mortels vous dites
quoi aux communs des mortels je lui dis
vigilance sur
dans l'espace numérique en général le
gouvernement travaille à mettre un
certain nombre de protection mais il
n'est pas question de de supprimer des
la liberté de télécharger sur son
téléphone personnel un certain nombre
d'applications soyez attentifs aux
Conditions Générales d'Utilisation soyez
attentifs aux données que ces
applications sollicitent de votre part
puisque on ne dans le monde numérique il
peut toujours y avoir des fuites il peut
toujours avoir des pertes de données et
il faut donc en avoir conscience au
moment où on accepte de gérer ces
données à soi pour montrer patte blanche
TikTok Gee qui vont créer des centres de
données en Europe
on est d'accord que c'est pas suffisant
parce que ça permet on peut très bien
les regarder vu de Chine c'est une bonne
chose que Tik Tok installe en Europe des
centres de données pour stocker les
données des utilisateurs européens c'est
l'esprit du rgpd moi je souhaite que les
autres éditeurs y compris les éditeurs
américains suivent ce mouvement là
puisque aujourd'hui ce n'est pas le cas
des éditeurs d'applications américains
et que ainsi les données des européens
soient traitées en Europe ce qui n'est
pas le cas encore une fois aujourd'hui
ce que je regrette c'est que le
calendrier que les responsables de Tik
Tok mon présenté soit aussi étendues
j'aurais souhaité que les choses
puissent aller beaucoup plus vite vous
voyez qu'il faut aller plus vite vous
êtes d'accord avec moi absolument moi
sur ce plan là d'accord donc vous leur
dites il faut aller plus vite c'est la
réponse pour conclure
la lettre d'Elon musk dont on a beaucoup
parlé évidemment avec ces milliers
d'autres
expérimentaux qui demandent de qui dit
il faut faire attention il faut faire
une pause tout ça va trop vite on le
voit bien depuis une demi-heure que nous
parlons ensemble il y a quand même
énormément d'interrogations est-ce que
vous vous dites banco on met on en fait
une pause certainement pas je pense que
certaines questions qui sont posées dans
cette lettre dans cette pétition sont
bonnes mais la réponse est évidemment
mauvaise mettre la recherche sur pause
reviendrait à donner un avantage à
toutes celles et ceux qui ne se
plairaient pas à ce à ce moratoire c'est
une solution qui n'est ni souhaitable ni
réaliste puisque ni souhaitable parce
que nous avons besoin de faire
progresser le l'intelligence
artificielle au service de nos
concitoyens mais de manière conforme au
principe auquel on est attaché ni
réaliste parce que la Chine par exemple
si Monsieur musk décrété un moratoire ou
si les États-Unis décrétaient un
moratoire ne s'y conformerait pas et la
Chine pourrait ainsi rattraper son
retard sur les États-Unis donc la bonne
solution c'est plutôt de fixer ces
fameuses bornes démocratiques éthique
pour faire en sorte que cette
technologie qui en elle-même nenni bonne
ni mauvaise puisse se mettre au service
de nos concitoyens au service des hommes
et que l'intelligence artificielle soit
au service de l'intelligence humaine
qu'est-ce que vous pensez en conclusion
du rôle d'Elon musk à la tête de Twitter
d'avoir je crois que la pétition
pourrait revenir de la semaine dernière
d'Elon musk sur l'intelligence
artificielle n'est pas dénué de
d'intérêt commerciaux puisque on voit
bien les concurrents de d'openhague et
de Microsoft essayez de ralentir la
progression de leur concurrents il
s'agissant de ce qu'il de ce qu'il a
accompli sur Twitter pour l'instant je
reste très dubitatif j'ai constaté vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure pendant le
journal qu'il avait qu'il entendait
dénigrer les les médias soutenus que la
radio les médias public sous-entendants
que le pluralisme est l'un de leur
indépendance n'était pas assurée le juge
de paix ça sera l'application du
règlement sur les services numériques
c'est-à-dire les règles nouvelles que
nous avons fixées en Europe auquel les
plateformes doivent se conformer sous
peine de voir de se voir infliger des
amendes allant jusqu'à 6% de leur
chiffre d'affaires c'est quand même 300
millions d'euros pour Twitter et en cas
de récidive l'interdiction d'opérer sur
le territoire numéro
là c'est important ça sera quand les
évaluations sont en cours et
l'application c'est au 1er janvier 2024
merci rendez-vous est pris merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous de nous
avoir dit un peu comment vous voyez
justement les les interdictions
peut-être les barrières à créer merci
beaucoup tout de suite vous savez
c'était Kenko présenté aujourd'hui par
Frédéric simotel vous pouvez retrouver
l'interview de Jean-Noël barreau sur le
QR code qui